your knee joint is made up of the
end of the femur which hinges on the
upper end of the tibia
and the patella or kneecap which slides
along the groove formed by the femoral
condyles total knee replacement surgery
is a procedure in which a painful or
poorly functioning knee is replaced with
artificial components if your physician
has recommended a total knee replacement
it is probably because your knee is
severely damaged by arthritis or injury
before your procedure you'll be given
intravenous fluids antibiotics and
medications to help you relax
a catheter may be placed in your bladder
to drain your urine knee replacement may
be done under general anesthesia in
which case a breathing tube will be
inserted in your throat to help you
breathe
during the operation or you may receive
spinal or epidural anesthesia in which
case you will remain awake throughout
the procedure but your legs will be
anesthetized since blood and fluid loss
is sometimes significant donated blood
may be prepared in case you require a
transfusion most total knee replacements
take approximately two hours your
surgeon will begin by making an incision
along the front edge of your knee after
separating the muscles and ligaments
around your knee your surgeon will
incise the knee capsule to gain access
to the inside of the joint using
specialized tools your surgeon will
remove the damaged bone and cartilage on
the ends of the femur and the tibia and
in most cases remove the underside of
the patella your surgeon will then
prepare the remaining bone to receive
your new prosthetic knee this generally
consists of a femoral a tibial and a
patellar component once the ends of the
bones are prepared your surgeon will
cement the new prostheses into position
before your incision is closed an x-ray
will be taken to ensure that the new
components of your knee are positioned
correctly your surgeon will close the
incision with stitches or staples and
temporarily leave a drain in place to
remove excess fluid
immediately following the operation a
splint will be applied to help hold your
knee in the appropriate position
you will then be moved to the recovery
area for monitoring if necessary you may
receive a blood transfusion at this time
once stable and awake from the
anesthesia you will be transferred to
your hospital room where you will
continue to receive intravenous
antibiotics for a short time and given
pain medications as needed to prevent
blood clots from forming in your leg you
will be given a blood thinner as to
where pneumatic compression stockings
and encouraged to begin walking as soon
as possible after the procedure a nurse
or physical therapist will help you get
out of bed and begin using your new knee
most patients are released from the
hospital once they are able to walk with
the aid of a crutch or walker